wir kommen damit zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
afghanistan afghanistan spielte heute
schon mal eine rolle allerdings sind
nicht in an diesem sitzungstag denn um
ein uhr nachts haben hier die
abgeordneten schon über einen
untersuchungsausschuss
entschieden
also praktisch der donnerstag zog sich
nämlich bis in den frühen freitagmorgen
freitag nacht hinein und dort haben dann
die abgeordneten entschieden dass es
einen untersuchungsausschuss geben soll
zum abzug der bundeswehr und zur
evakuierung aus afghanistan welche
fehler damals gemacht wurden was es für
konsequenzen daraus geben muss und jetzt
geht es auch um den afghanistan einsatz
allerdings nicht
direkt um den abzug sondern um das
engagement insgesamt dazu soll eine
kommission eingerichtet werden die also
dass militärische und auch das zivile
engagement in afghanistan beleuchtet und
daraus lehren zieht dazu gibt es einen
antrag
fraktionsübergreifend und china gaben
wir spricht als erstes für die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen
nächsten monat jährt sich der chaotische
abzug der streitkräfte aus afghanistan
zum ersten mal seit diesem tag laufen
die uhren rückwärts
frauen und mädchen werden unsichtbar
gemacht sie werden ihres rechts auf
bildung und teilhabe braucht ihre
hoffnung auf gleichberechtigung und
sicherheit haben sich nicht erfüllt
gleiches gilt für die ortskräfte für
frauenrechtlerin medienschaffende und
mitarbeitende von zivil organisationen
sie haben sich über jahre für
fortschritt eingesetzt ihre erfolge
wurden innerhalb kürzester zeit
rückgängig gemacht sie alle leben heute
in großer gefahr und in einem die
lebensumstände all dieser menschen
gruppen spiegeln dabei die aktuelle lage
im land wieder der alltag und das leben
in afghanistan ist von verzweiflung und
hoffnungslosigkeit geprägt das ergebnis
unseres 20-jährigen militärischen
entwicklungspolitischen humanitären und
diplomatischen engagement in afghanistan
ist leider kein demokratisches und
sicheres land auf dem weg in eine
bessere zukunft im gegenteil das
ergebnis ist ein geschundenes land in
einem katastrophalen zustand aktuell
ohne perspektive auf besserung das muss
aufgearbeitet werden genau hier wird die
enquete-kommission ansetzen
sie wird ein teil dazu beitragen dass
wir unser versprechen einlösen dass wir
verantwortung übernehmen und dass wir
afghanistan nicht vergessen
wir werden systematisch und
selbstkritisch analysieren wie es zu
diesen schweren versagen auf
verschiedenen ebenen kommen konnte dazu
werden will mit hilfe von
wissenschaftlerinnen und menschen aus
der praxis die verschiedenen strukturen
und prozesse beleuchten wir werden die
fehler die wir gemacht haben erkennen
und benennen und wir werden für die
zukunft erarbeiten wie es besser gehen
kann was sind wir die menschen in
afghanistan schuldig die so viel
hoffnung in irland hatten die sich für
eine bessere zukunft für freiheit
eingesetzt haben das sind wir aber auch
den soldaten entschuldigt und den
polizistinnen die wir in die einsätze
geschickt haben und all denjenigen die
sich über jahre im rahmen ihrer arbeit
für die zivilgesellschaft für ein
besseres afghanistan eingesetzt haben
liebe kollegin zur wahrheit gehört
leider auch dazu die enquete kommission
wird viel zurückblicken und die lehren
die wir daraus für die zukunft ziehen
helfen aktuell nicht nicht gegen die
taliban und nicht gegen die dramatischen
auswirkungen des erdbebens wir müssen
zukünftig also auch dem anderen teil
unserer verantwortung nachkommen und den
menschen in afghanistan in ihrer
aktuellen lage helfen besonders den
frauen und mädchen den medienschaffenden
und den kritischen stimmen im land ihm
gebührt unsere volle unterstützung denn
sie sind der einzige hoffnung die länder
china gambier war dass sie selbst ist in
kabul geboren und hat hier die debatte
zur einsetzung einer enquete-kommission
zum einsatz in afghanistan eröffnet
johann wadephul spricht jetzt für die
lieben kollegen kollegen es gehört zu
den wichtigsten aufgaben dieses hauses
mandat für den einsatz unserer
soldatinnen soldaten zu beschließen dass
dies überhaupt geschieht liegt daran
dass die möglichkeit besteht dass
soldatinnen soldaten möglicherweise in
bewaffnete auseinandersetzung geraten
können dass sie in gefahr geraten können
deswegen sind die debatten die wir hier
regelmäßig zu mandaten führen immer von
großer ernsthaftigkeit geprägt von dem
wissen bei uns allen dass wir mit
unseren stimmen soldatinnen und soldaten
in potenziell gefährliche missionen
senden wir tun dies in überzeugung dass
dies für die sicherheit unseres landes
und der sicherheit unserer verbündeten
und partner notwendig ist wir tun dies
mit dem wissen um die verantwortung die
wir jede einzelne abgeordnete jeder
abgeordnete bundestages für die
soldatinnen soldaten übernimmt wohl in
keinem der einsätze ist dies so deutlich
geworden wie in afghanistan
20 jahre lang war deutschland dort
engagiert weit über 90.000 soldaten
soldaten sind dort einige mehrfach
einige sechs bis acht mal im einsatz
gewesen und wir haben hier im parlament
über 20 mandate mit bezug auf
afghanistan beschlossen am ende dieses
engagement mussten wir vor bald einem
jahr eine ehrliche und eine nüchterne
bilanz ziehen wir haben in 20 jahren
viel erreicht für 20 jahre war
afghanistan kein rückzugsort mehr für
internationalen terrorismus gegen von
dort keine anschläge mehr aus für 20
jahre haben dort frauen und vor allem
mädchen rechte genossen durften schulen
und universitäten besuchen durften
berufen nachgehen sowie jahrzehnte vor
zuvor nicht vielleicht sogar nie zuvor
in der geschichte dieses landes 20 jahre
lang gab es wahlen gab es einen
kritischen journalisten und gab es
rechte für religiöse und ethnische
minderheiten 20 jahre lang war
afghanistan ein land mit großen
herausforderungen und riesigen problemen
aber es war ein land mit einer jungen
generation
voller hoffnung und mit potenzial dafür
haben wir zusammen mit unseren
verbündeten und partnern viel
interessiert
investiert an ressourcen an geld zeit
und wir haben schmerzhafte verluste
hinnehmen müssen vor allem bei der
bundeswehr mit ihren gefallenen mit
ihren umgekommenen mit den vielen an
leib und seele verwundeten wir waren
erfolgreich aber es war schmerzhaft und
deswegen ein großer dank an alle
soldatinnen soldaten an sich die
diplomaten diplomaten unsere polizisten
viele spezialisten in den weg kommt ihre
organisationen in allen gebührt dank für
ihren jahrelangen entbehrungsreichen
einsatz
doch nach 20 jahren brachen im grunde
die meine vorredner hat das auch schon
zum ausdruck gebracht alle erfolge weg
und afghanistan ist mit der
machtübernahme der taliban scheint
wieder zurück katapultiert in eine vor
zeit zurück in zeiten der in zeiten der
intoleranz des terrors und der
hoffnungslosigkeit
wir alle haben uns vor fast einem jahr
als die taliban blitzartig das land
überrannten die frage gestellt was
falsch gelaufen ist haben wir was was
haben wir verkehrt gemacht diese fragen
sind nach wie vor relevant denn zum
einen wollen wir dass uns dass unsere
anderen engagement und anderen regionen
der welt ich denke nur an die sahel zone
dauerhaft und nachhaltig erfolgreich
sind wir müssen für die zukunft lernen
denn es ist klar dass wir auch zukünftig
engagiert bleiben müssen in der welt um
unsere sicherheit zu gewährleisten um
unseren internationalen verantwortung
gerecht zu werden zum anderen sind wir
ist den menschen die für unser land mit
und ohne uniform nach afghanistan
gegangen sind schuldig uns kritisch zu
hinterfragen ob wir die richtigen
strategien verfolgt haben deswegen haben
sich die demokratischen fraktionen
dieses hohen hauses zusammengeschlossen
um eine enquetekommission mit einem
gemeinsamen formulierten antrag
einzusetzen eine enquete die kritisch
analytisch auf unser engagement in
afghanistan zurück blickt um antworten
für zukünftige engagement zu finden dass
wir die fraktion der fdp der grünen der
spd der cdu csu uns gemeinsam zusammen
gefunden haben ist natürlich kein zufall
denn wir alle haben in den letzten 20
jahren verantwortung übernommen für
diese engagement es jeweils in
regierungsverantwortung
teilweise ja auch in der opposition
wir alle tragen deshalb politische
verantwortung für das was geschehen ist
und wir sind auch im nachhinein
überzeugt dass das engagement
grundsätzlich richtig war aber wir
wollen und sind daran interessiert zu
wissen was wir zukünftig besser machen
können und deswegen braucht es eine echt
tiefgreifende analyse und eine breit
angelegte untersuchung mit
handlungsempfehlungen für die zukunft
deshalb wird meine fraktion der
einsetzung dieser enquete kommission
zustimmen herzlichen dank für die
auflösung
zwölf mitglieder soll diese enquete
kommission zu afghanistan haben und auch
der vorsitzende steht schon fest und das
ist michael müller von der spd und er
spricht jetzt ja auch in der debatte
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
mein kollege ralf stegner hat in seinen
reden zur einsetzung des
untersuchungsausschusses
afghanistan immer wieder erinnert an die
schrecklichen bilder die wir auch alle
noch im kopf haben die bilder die
entstanden sind als so abrupt unser
einsatz der deutschen soldatinnen und
soldaten der entwicklungshelfer endete
als tausende menschen noch verzweifelt
versucht haben sich und ihre familien in
sicherheit zu bringen nach unserem abzug
meine damen und herren ist es richtig
dass das aufgearbeitet wird in einem
untersuchungsausschuss aber es ist
genauso richtig und wichtig dass wir
heute noch einen schritt weiter gehen
einen wichtigen schritt nämlich mit der
einsetzung dieser enquete kommission die
eben nicht nur das ende unseres
engagement betrachtet sondern die
gesamten zeitraum die 20 jahre unseres
engagement in afghanistan
es geht darum zu gucken wie wir
humanitär finanziell militärisch helfen
konnten es geht darum den gesamten
außen- sicherheits- und sieht
entwicklungspolitischen einsatz unseres
landes zu betrachten und daraus
schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen und ja
meine damen und herren glaube er war
wohl hat recht es hat viele erfolge
gegeben
wir haben milliarden eingesetzt für
entwicklungs und humanitäre hilfe wir
haben erfolge hat im kampf gegen den
terror krankenhäuser und schulen wurden
gebaut insbesondere in den städten
hatten frauen die chance
arbeitsplätze zu bekommen in die
universitäten zu gehen mädchen konnten
schulen besuchen die kindersterblichkeit
des zurückgegangen von berufsausbildung
angeboten profitieren viele von heute
bestimmt und trotzdem muss man klar
sagen
die bilanz nach 20 jahren unseres
engagements ist ernüchternd die
hinterlassen ein bitter armes
zerrissenes und des funktionales land
die erneute machtübernahme der taliban
dauerte nur wenige tage afghanische
streitkräfte über viele jahre mit großem
einsatz aufgebaut sind praktisch über
nacht zusammengebrochen wir haben keine
halbwegs funktionierenden staatlichen
oder demokratischen strukturen im land
es ist uns auch nicht wirklich gelungen
im land nicht in den städten im land für
unser engagement ausreichend vertrauen
und loyalität in der bevölkerung zu
gewinnen ohnehin
ausserhalb der städte war die situation
immer besonders schwierig die
wirtschaftskrise verstärkt das jetzt
noch zusätzlich menschenrechtsverletzung
repressionen insbesondere gegen frauen
sind leider wieder auch an der
tagesordnung aber meine damen und herren
zur wahl gehört auch dazu noch vor dem
am zug jedes jahr hat es im land mehrere
tausend zivile opfer durch kampfhandlung
gegeben alleine 2020
2500 versehrte oder getötete kinder das
heißt auch während unseres einsatzes
gehört afghanistan zu den freiesten
ländern der welt wir haben keine
dauerhafte befriedung hinbekommen meine
damen und herren weil das macht deutlich
es dringend geboten die verschiedenen
einsätze und missionen zum kampf gegen
den terror zur stabilisierung zur
etablierung von rechtsstaatlichen
strukturen zur verbesserten
regierungsarbeit in afghanistan
aufzuarbeiten und neben dem
untersuchungsausschuss haben wir ja
festgehalten dass das in einer kurve in
einer enquetekommission
auch stattfinden soll und dass ihr aber
vor allen dingen nicht nur zurückblicken
wollen sondern vor allen dingen auch
schlussfolgerungen für die zukunft
ziehen wollen mit wissenschaftlicher
expertise wollen und werden wir die
vergangenen 20 jahre evaluieren
kenntnisse praxisnah formulieren
zukunftsgerichtet aufbereiten und so vor
allen dingen für zukünftige
auslandseinsätze glaube ich wichtige
erkenntnisse weitergeben können von
besonderer bedeutung ist vor diesem
hintergrund für mich die analyse des
vernetzten ansatzes also das
zusammenspiel von militär diplomatie
entwicklungshilfe von lokalen
institutionen und den akteuren vor ort
denn das muss es doch sein
der vernetzte ansatz darf doch nicht nur
bedeuten dass wir hier vor ort ressort
übergreifend zusammenarbeiten und über
unsere einsätze uns auseinandersetzen
schon dass es schwierig genug oft nein
der vernetzte ansatz muss bedeuten die
menschen vor ort mit einzubeziehen vor
jedem einsatz muss es zwingend von
expertinnen und experten analysen geben
zu den verhältnissen vor ort was es
überhaupt ein realistisches ziel gibt es
strukturen die man nutzen kann können
wir mit unseren mitteln eine
gesellschaft nach unseren maßstäben
verändern haben wir uns vor unserem
engagement wirklich intensiv mit
geschichte und kultur mit der situation
vor ort auseinander gesetzt meine damen
und herren aus begangenen fehlern falsch
gesetzten prioritäten aus unrealistisch
gesetzten zielen müssen wir lernen die
liste der länder in denen wir jetzt
schon aktiv sind ist lang mal sudan irak
mögen noch so unterschiedlich sein und
doch glaube ich ist es zwingend dass wir
allein dafür lernen aus gemachten
fehlern um uns dort jetzt besser
engagieren zu können und erst recht gilt
das für unser engagement an der zukunft
nur so kann deutschland seinen beitrag
zur nachhaltigen friedensbemühungen und
internationaler sicherheit leisten es
reicht nicht allein edle ambitionen zu
haben sondern wir müssen realistisch und
umsetzbare ziele definieren in der
enquetekommission glaube ich haben wir
dazu die chance das transparent sachlich
und kompetent zu erarbeiten mit der
einbindung viele expertinnen und
experten wissenschaftlern mit
beteiligten institutionen vor ort und
daraus wollen und werden wir unsere
schlussfolgerung ziehen nach 20 jährigem
engagement sind wir das glaube ich auch
den tausenden opfern den vielen orts-
kräften von den tausenden auch noch auf
die evakuierung warten den getöteten
entwicklungshelfern und getöteten
soldatinnen und soldaten schuldig fehler
die gemacht wurden dürfen sich nicht
wiederholen
meine damen und herren abschließend will
ich mich bedanken bei den
koalitionsfraktionen die sich
konstruktiv in die erarbeitung unseres
einsetzung des beschlusses eingebracht
haben aber auch bei der cdu csu die
genauso konstruktiv mitgewirkt hat ich
glaube es ist eine gute grundlage zu
spüren dass regierung und opposition
hier gemeinsam sich etwas vorgenommen
haben um diesen wichtigen auftrag zu
erfüllen dafür ein großes dankeschön und
ich freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit
soweit michael müller ehemaliger
bürgermeister in berlin und jetzt
demnächst vorsitzender der
enquete-kommission
stefan kräuter spricht jetzt für die fdp
fraktion auch er sitzt im auswärtigen
ausschuss
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir diskutieren hier
seit einigen wochen in diesem hohen haus
ein untersuchungsausschuss afghanistan
auf der anderen seite eine
enquetekommission afghanistan und roms
jetzt ist genau das eingetreten wovor
ich vor zwei wochen gewarnt habe nämlich
dass ein untersuchungsausschuss
eingesetzt wird der sich lediglich mit
dem desaströsen abzug ich sage es mal
der flucht aus afghanistan befasst und
nicht um die aufarbeitung der
versäumnisse der letzten 20 jahre da
liegt nämlich das problem die ursache
für das scheitern dieser mission in
afghanistan
die dutzende unserer landsleute soldaten
und bundespolizisten das leben gekostet
haben was wir was wir hier einsetzen ist
eine enquetekommission aber kommen
zurück auf den untersuchungsausschuss
der untersuchungsausschuss ist heute
nacht um 00 40 in diesem hohen hause
beschlossen worden kurz vor der beratung
des ochsen gesetzes und eine stunde
bevor wir meine fraktion durch ein
hammelsprung dieses unwürdige treiben in
diesem hohen haus ohne
beschlussfähigkeit beendet haben
gerade eben ist dieser
untersuchungsausschuss konstituiert
worden und wie gesagt die die beratungen
über den untersuchungsausschuss werden
wir führen er bezieht sich allerdings
nur auf das ende der mission die enquete
kommission hat eine ganz andere
zielsetzung wenn wir unsere einmal die
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages angucken steht dort in
paragraf 56 der sich mit enquete
kommission beschäftigt in satz eins ich
zitiere zur vorbereitung von
entscheidungen über umfangreiche und
bedeutsame sache komplexer kann der
bundestag eine enquetekommission
einsetzen
für alle zuschauer oben auf den rängen
geklärt hier ist konsensual es handeln
und ein konsens erforderlich dieser
konsens kann nicht gegeben sein wenn die
versäumnisse
fehler der vergangenheit nicht
ordentlich aufgearbeitet worden sind
wir diskutieren über zukünftige
auswirkungen von künftigen
entscheidungen eine enquetekommission
über zwei jahre aber ich frage sie warum
ist eine weitere aufarbeitung diesem
hohen hause nicht gewollt ich habe es
ihm vor zwei jahren gesagt ich befürchte
dass eine krähe der anderen kein auge
aus sagt und die verantwortlichen für
das scheitern in afghanistan für diesen
desaströsen einsatz der sitzt hier vor
mir spd cdu csu sind die
hauptverantwortlichen für dieses
scheitern für das verbrennen von
milliarden deutschen steuergeldes für
tote landsleute und für eine flucht aus
afghanistan die in afghanistan
verbrannte erde hinterlässt was sie
wollen ist ein therapeutisches
aufarbeiten dieses scheiterns gerade
soviel wieder bürger vertragen kann aber
gerade auch nur so viel um sich aus der
verantwortung zu stehlen
schauen wir einmal in den sommer 20 21
zurück letztes jahr der herr lindner
heute bundesfinanzminister von der fdp
der leider die regierungsbank leer
gefegt hatte ich sehe keinen einzigen
bundesminister hier verheiratet gerade
auf sylt einen schönen gruß dahin
herzlichen glückwunsch und viel glück
für die zukunft er hätte sich aber
vielleicht ein anderer tag aussuchen
können außerhalb einer sitzungswoche
dass es schon sehr beschämt wir schauen
riesigen krisen energie und sicherheit
diesem land entgegen und auf sylt findet
gerade die große party der
bundesregierung statt außerdem hat frau
beerbach heute bundes außenministerin
zusammen mit den winter erklärt eine
umfangreiche aufarbeitung dieses
scheitern wird in einem
untersuchungsausschuss erfolg kaum sind
sie in regierungsverantwortung ist das
schnee von gestern klar nach dem motto
wasch wer stört mich mein geschwätz von
gestern
diese enquete kommission werden wir
nicht zustimmen es ist eine farce wir
haben eine verpflichtung gegenüber den
opfern der wehr wir mit einer
enquetekommission so nicht gerecht oder
ein letztes wort zu programmieren die
gerade eben vor mir gesprochen hatte von
den grünen sind noch nicht so lange hier
diesen politikgeschäft drin sie sagten
eben wir tragen eine verantwortung für
die menschen in afghanistan in erster
linie programmen wir tragen wir eine
verantwortung für unsere landsleute und
für die familien unserer landsleute
insbesondere der soldaten die wir hier
auch gedenken die in diesem einsatz
gefallen sind vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
stefan kreuzer war das hat hier eine
weitgehendere aufarbeitung gefordert
und ist rednerin ist marie agnes strack
zimmermann für die fdp und vorsitzende
des verteidigungsausschusses
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren ich sag nur schäbig willich
unwürdig ab meine damen und herren
kein auslandseinsatz hat so viele spuren
in der bundeswehr in der gesellschaft
hinterlassen wie der einsatz in
afghanistan
allen voran natürlich bei den
soldatinnen und soldaten die dort im
laufe der 20 jahre oft mehrmals im
einsatz waren die dort auch kämpfen
mussten auch kameraden zu grabe haben
tragen müssen und viele an den folgen
des einsatzes auch heute noch leiden
ihnen und deren familien die diese
einsätze mitgetragen mitgelitten und
auch angehörige verloren haben ihnen
geht unser großer tief empfunden der
dank
unser respekt
unser respekt gehört den soldatinnen und
soldaten die ihren auftrag mit bravour
erfüllt haben die dieses parlament
gewollt hat und der ruf der bundeswehr
ist deswegen auch so gut international
weil die soldatinnen und soldaten und
viele andere dazu beigetragen haben
meine damen und herren deutschlands
engagement am hindukusch hat maßgeblich
dazu beigetragen wie sich die
anforderungen an die bundeswehr
verändert haben struktur und ausbildung
der streitkräfte wurden auf das
internationale krisen management
ausgerichtet und für diejenigen die sich
in dieser zeit bei der bundeswehr
verpflichtet war klar dass sie ihr weg
früher oder später nach masar i scharif
kabul oder kundus führt und nein es war
nicht alles schlecht
hunderttausende soldatinnen und soldaten
aber auch zivile mitarbeiterinnen
polizisten helfer und diplomatinnen
haben mit großem persönlichen einsatz
ihr bestes gegeben dieses land zu
stabilisieren zu modernisieren den
menschen zu helfen frauen eine bessere
zukunft zu ermöglichen und für
sicherheit zu sorgen
und ja es ist bitter
trotz alledem steht in afghanistan am
ende der vollständige kollaps einer
staatlichen ordnung trotz alledem müssen
sich frauen in der öffentlichkeit wieder
voll verschleiern trotzdem dürfen
mädchen nicht mehr auf weiterführenden
schulen trotzdem ist menschen auf deren
hilfe wir uns jahrelang verlassen haben
in ihrer heimat um ihr leben fürchten
auch weil wir bis heute sie nicht alle
aus geholt haben und ja bei allen vielen
bleiben die dramatischen bilder von
kabuler flughafen gewissermaßen als
schlussakt aber leider auch nur dazu
dass die ehemalige ministerin
kramp-karrenbauer als letzte kontingent
am 30 juni 20 21 am luftwaffenstützpunkt
wunstorf ankam selbst in usa weiter der
generalinspekteur in berlin und die
mitglieder unseres aus dass es noch
andere erst am frühen morgen davon
erfahren haben wir hatten keine keine
chance mehr dort hinzukommen gewartet
hat dort eine fernsehstation eine
hörfunksender und einer agentur meine
damen und herren ich stell mir nicht
noch heute und es ist unfassbar dass wir
keine gelegenheit hatten dieses
kontingent persönlich in empfang zu
nehmen
meine damen und herren heute kommt diese
emission wir setzen sie ein und in
diesen 20 jahren und das ist wichtig ist
uns auch was gelungen nämlich dass es
eine grad in den großstädten eine
generation gibt einer modernen jungen
generation und ja die fehler über die
wir sprechen über die werden wir
sprechen müssen das fehlende verständnis
für kultur und der dortigen gesellschaft
auch die naive herangehensweise mal so
eben aus afghanistan ein modernes land
westlicher lebensart machen zu wollen
die grobe fehleinschätzungen über den
rückhalt der taliban vor allem fernab
der großen städte und unsummen von geld
welches ins land floss und auch
korruption gedeihen links und meine
damen und herren letztlich der
überstürztes wurde gesagt planloser
abzug und das komplette verkennen der
wehr heftig wer fähigkeit und der
billigkeit der afghanischen armee es
gilt daher lehren aus diesem einsatz zu
ziehen und natürlich besonders um aus
den erfahrungen heraus in zukunft diese
fehler nicht mehr zu wiederholen meine
damen und herren eine unabhängige
evaluierung des afghanistan-einsatzes
hätte schon viel früher erfolgen müssen
und herr wadephul wir haben das als fdp
immer von ihnen und ihrer den ministerin
gefordert dass kam nie und wenn ich mit
verlaub jetzt sehe wie viel von ihrer
fraktion an diesem wichtigen
afghanistan-einsatz noch hier ist das
finde ich bemerkenswert
auch in der opposition hat man
verantwortung zu übernehmen vor allem an
den größten teil dieses einsatzes die
inhaber der kommando und befehlsgewalt
geführt hat und meine damen und herren
wir holen das jetzt nach die ampel hat
bereits angefangen die laufenden
einsätze zu evaluieren und entsprechend
anzupassen vor allem was das mandat mali
betrifft die reflektion muss standard
sein wir haben eine verantwortung für
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten und für
die menschen die darauf hoffen dass sie
auch ein menschenwürdiges leben führen
müssen und auch darauf bauen dass wir
sie dabei in ihren ländern unterstützen
hilden
marianne strack zimmermann
war das hat hier schon gesagt die
aufarbeitung findet eigentlich zu spät
statt aber immerhin findet statt dass
wenn wir dann nach der sommerpause das
ein oder andere mal uns damit
beschäftigen sie wien da drinnen spricht
jetzt für die linksfraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
20 jahre krieg nato krieg in afghanistan
sollen jetzt in einer zahnlosen an cat
kommission abgehandelt werden
200.000 getöteten afghanen 59 tote
bundeswehrsoldaten
und 12,5 milliarden euro kriegsschulden
für diesen sinnlosen und abenteuerlichen
krieg der nato für all das haben sie ja
da haben sie gut lachen obwohl von union
spd fdp und grünen hier 20 jahre lang
die hand gehoben und jeder jeder
mandatsverlängerung zugestimmt dieser
schmutziger krieg der westlichen
militärallianz am hindukusch mit dem
vielen kriegsverbrechen auch vom nato
starken ruf nach aufklärung und auch
ihre fließband artige mandatierung hier
im bundestag ruft nach aufklärung die
kriegs lügen die diesen einsatz
rechtfertigten mit denen der
öffentlichkeit vorgegaukelt wurde es
immer um um rechte und das bohren von
brunnen rufe nach aufklärung aber die
ganz große koalition in diesem haus die
kriegskoalition
verweigert dazu einem
untersuchungsausschuss achtern leistung
meter afghanische leben szenen für sie
nicht und das ist unglaublich dass sie
dieses von ihnen mit angerichtete
desaster diese katastrophe jetzt in
einer kommission ohne kompetenzen ab
handeln wollen ihnen geht es nicht um
aufklärung
ihnen geht es auch nicht um
untersuchungen und schon gar nicht
wollen sie irgendwelche vorschriften
konsequenzen ziehen bei ihnen steht das
ergebnis schon fest sie wollen
vertuschen und die öffentlichkeit weiter
täuschen um dann zu sagen wir machen
weiter mit neuen afghanistans in der
sahelzone in mali inmedea das sind jetzt
die länder indem wir auf kosten der
bevölkerung nun unseren geopolitischen
fußabdruck nach afghanistan hinterlassen
wollen und das finden wir als linke eine
schande sie wollen sie wollen nichts
lernen sie wollen nicht aufklären sie
wollen einfach nur weitermachen wie
bisher koste es was es wolle
weder das leben der menschen in
afghanistan noch der deutschen soldaten
zu etwas für sie und die gründlichste
entlassung das sage ich ihnen ihre
wahren absichten ist gegen weigerung den
menschen jetzt in afghanistan humanitär
zu helfen werden es wurden seitens der
nato noch täglich jeden tag 300
millionen dollar kabbala und jetzt nun
an die menschen dort und wäre die
menschen dort in afghanistan hungern
haben sie in deutschland hunderte
millionen dollar an afghanischen
staatsgeldern einfach eingefroren in den
banken hunger als waffe einzusetzen ist
abgrundtief böse meinen tag und lassen
sie das geben sie das afghanische geld
in deutschland endlich frei damit man
der bevölkerung mit lebensmitteln
dort helfen kann und machen sie den weg
frei das sind ja ihre freunde die
taliban mit ihm haben sie in doha
verhandelt und machen sie den weg frei
für eine untersuchung der westlichen
kriegsverbrechen in afghanistan das kann
eine kommission mit ihren ketten nicht
leisten meine damen und herren nur wer
bereit ist die vergangenheit wirklich zu
bearbeiten ist nicht verdammt dazu diese
vergangenheit in der zukunft zu
wiederholen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen philipp krämer
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich glaube das was wir eben
gehört haben kriegskoalition hunger als
waffe taliban als freunde ist eine
umkehrung der realität und es
insbesondere in zeiten eines krieges in
europa und einer kappe einer
konsequenten fehleinschätzung der
außenpolitischen lage der linkspartei
gezeichnet und den sollten wir hier
nicht folgen
der 20 jährige krieg in afghanistan war
bisher das prägendste ereignis wer nicht
ein prägender zustand meiner generation
als er begann war ich neun jahre alt nun
als er mit dem alliierten abzug endete
bin ich 20 jahre älter noch viel prägen
dabei allerdings für die menschen in
afghanistan und die soldatinnen und
soldaten den ihm gedient ihr leben
riskiert und vielfach verloren haben
ihnen deutschen und alliierten soldaten
soldaten ihren familien und freunden
gilt unser dank und mitgefühl ebenso den
afghanischen partnerinnen und partnern
der dortigen zivilbevölkerung die wie
niemand sonst in diesem krieg gelitten
hat und heute erneut unter der
gewaltherrschaft der taliban leiden muss
auch wenn der russische angriffskrieg
einen neuen außenpolitischen und auch
militärischen paradigmenwechsel hin zur
landes- und bündnisverteidigung bedeutet
können wir internationale einsätze und
humanitäre militärische intervention mit
deutscher beteiligung in der zukunft
nicht mit gewissheit ausschließen
daher wollen wir uns mitte einzusetzen
und cat kommission mit den lektionen aus
diesen 20 jahren krieg in einer
multinationalen koalition
auseinandersetzen was lief gut was lief
falsch was muss besser werden wie können
wir die leben unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten der zivilbevölkerung aber auch
der eingesetzten polizisten polizisten
wie auch dass einer dem krieg und
terroristen ausgelieferten
zivilbevölkerung besser schonen und
schützen die koalition
truppen konnten auch unter widrigen
bedingungen fast jedem militärischen
einzel auftrag auch erfüllen dieser
krieg wurde politisch verloren die
regierungs mission kabul symbolisiert
die niederlage auf tragische art und
weise genau deshalb müssen wir uns die
verschiedenen dimensionen und ebenen
dieses multinational vernetzten
einsatzes und ihr zusammenspiel
gründlich anschauen
regelmäßige evaluation und selbstkritik
bereits während des krieges meine
vorrednerin hatten es auch angesprochen
hat hätten den einsatz eventuell zu
einem positiveren einsatz führen können
leider hat auch dieses voraus dass
wiederholt abgelehnt lernen wir nun also
gemeinsam aus den fehlern der
vergangenheit ergebnis offen und
selbstkritisch und das unterscheidet uns
glaube ich auch hier von der linkspartei
selbstkritisch und besser ausgerüstet in
die zukunft gehen zu können als
bundeswehr als politik als gesellschaft
lassen uns zügig nach der sommerpause
mit der arbeit beginnen ich freue mich
darauf herzlichen dank für die
gemeinsame initiative der ampel und eben
auch der cdu/csu-fraktion
philipp krämer hat sich hier noch mal
bei den fraktionen bedankt den dies ist
ein interfraktioneller antrag wie er
gesagt hat auch von der unionsfraktion
mitgetragen und für die unionsfraktion
spricht jetzt susanne hier
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir leben in einer unsicheren welt mit
dem angriff russlands auf die ukraine am
24 februar diesen jahres ist die
erkenntnis dass frieden keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist bei uns in
europa wieder in den fokus gerückt
unsere gewohnte art in freiheit
sicherheit und wohlstand zu leben ist
wieder selbstverständlich noch ist sie
auf dauer garantiert vor unserer
haustüre den krieg gegen freiheit und
unabhängigkeit
der ukraine und damit auch gegen die
westliche welt ordnung geführt das ist
im moment die unmittelbarste bedrohung
für uns sie ist aber bei weitem nicht
die einzige internationale terrorismus
fragile staatlichkeit
irreguläre migration und der klimawandel
werden die welt in zukunft weiter
destabilisieren und wir werden dabei
nicht zuschauen dürfen als größtes land
europas haben wir eine verantwortung
einen beitrag zu frieden und stabilität
in der welt zu leisten
dieser beitrag wird und das wissen wir
aus der erfahrung der vergangenheit
nicht nur eindimensional sein sondern
immer ein zusammenspiel von
verschiedenen akteuren wie zum beispiel
polizei militär und
zivilgesellschaft erfordern
genauso wenig werden die
herausforderungen allein mit
militärischen mitteln lösbar sein
sondern nur ressort übergreifend mit
verbundenen einsatz von diplomatie
entwicklungszusammenarbeit oder beratung
unser beitrag zur internationalen
sicherheit und stabilität wird dabei
immer im zusammenspiel mit den
europäischen institutionen und unseren
verbündeten unter anderem in der nato
erfolgen deutschland muss seiner
verantwortung in europa und der welt
gerecht werden
ereignisse von weltpolitischer bedeutung
ereignisse die aktuelles handeln
erfordern lassen sich nicht voraussagen
auch die einsätze der vergangenheit
konnten nicht langfristig vorhergesehen
werden mit den anschlägen am 11
september 2001 wurde schnelles handeln
genauso wichtig und notwendig wie mit
dem
vorspiel entschied in der milizen in
mali im januar 2012 durch diese
geschehnisse waren wir gezwungen in
afghanistan bzw in mali zu agieren ohne
dass wir eine chance hatten uns
langfristig darauf vorzubereiten
wir haben uns diese aus einsätze nicht
ausgesucht und wir beabsichtigen auch
nicht dass für die zukunft zu tun es
können aber immer wieder solche
situationen entstehen in denen wir
erneut handeln müssen weil es politisch
notwendig sein wird die wichtigste
vorbereitung auf solche zukünftige
einsätze ist es die vergangenen einsätze
zu bewerten und unseren ressort
übergreifenden instrumentenkasten zu
verbessern dies ist nicht nur die
aufgabe der regierung sondern
insbesondere auch die aufgabe für uns
als parlament denn wir entscheiden
letztendlich am ende über jeden einsatz
diese enquete kommission zum einsatz in
afghanistan
setzt für solch eine bewertung genau den
richtigen rahmen
auch wenn das ende des einsatzes eine
katastrophe war mit der sich der gestern
eingesetzte untersuchungsausschuss
beschäftigen wird können deswegen nicht
die gesamten 20 jahre des einsatzes am
hindukusch pauschal als fehlschlag
interpretiert werden wir haben in diesen
20 jahren viel über die möglichkeiten
und grenzen unseres vernetzten ansatzes
erfahren diese erfahrungen wollen wir in
den nächsten monaten zusammenführen
bewerten und daraus
handlungsempfehlungen für die zukunft
ableiten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
vergangenheit können wir nicht mehr
ändern aber wir können aus unserem
vergangenen handeln lernen und so einen
wirkungsvollen beitrag zu mehr
sicherheit und stabilität in der welt
leisten
dazu wird die enquete kommission im
beitrag leisten herzlichen
susanne hir war das für die
unionsfraktion die spd fraktion hat
schon eine sprecherin gewählt für diese
am cat kommission und das ist die riaa
türk nachbauer die hier die letzte
rednerin in dieser debatte ist
der frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
wer in der zukunft lesen will muss in
der vergangenheit blättern wir wir sind
entschlossen in der zukunft zu lesen und
werden daher gemeinsam nüchtern und
sachlich die vergangenen 20 jahre seit
dem beginn des afghanistan-einsatzes
durchblättern analysieren verstehen um
daraus lehren zu ziehen es ist gut dass
wir jetzt eines unserer weiteren viele
im koalitionsvertrag erfüllen wir wollen
eine auch jetzt kommission wir setzen
sie jetzt ein dieser hat den auftrag den
einsatz der bundeswehr in afghanistan
aufzuarbeiten der unionsfraktion danke
ich für deren unterstützung denn die
zusammenarbeit in der enquetekommission
erfordert eine lösungsorientierte
kooperation aller demokratischen
parlamentarierin und kommentar
das ist wichtig denn dieser afghanistan
einsatz wo den deutschland von
unterschiedlichsten regierungsbündnissen
getragen somit sagen alle daran
beteiligt nach verantwortung dafür wir
werden vielfältige aspekte aufarbeiten
sie sich nicht auf den bloßen
militäreinsatz reduzieren lassen nicht
umsonst sprechen wir hier von einem
vernetzten engagement es werden damit
alle bereiche von verteidigung bis hin
zur entwicklungszusammenarbeit und den
menschenrechten miteinander verknüpft im
zentrum wird die beantwortung der frage
stehen warum es uns nicht gelungen ist
afghanistan dauerhaft zu befrieden
welche ziele haben wir uns im jahr 2001
gesetz wie haben sie denn überhaupt
definiert und wie haben wir unsere ziele
im laufe dieses einsatzes angepasst die
damit einhergehenden herausforderungen
denen sich die bundeswehr sowie die
zivilen akteurinnen in den knapp 20
jahren gestellt haben wollen wir
untersuchen und gründlich abklopfen für
die künftige konzeptionierung möglicher
anderer einsätze können wir dann aus
diesem erfahrungsschatz schöpfen aus den
gewonnenen erkenntnissen aus der analyse
dieses einsatzes werden wir unsere
lehren ziehen in der geschichte unseres
parlaments gab es zudem noch nie eine
enquete kommission die sich in diesem
ausmaß mit außenpolitischen und
militärischen fragen beschäftigt hat da
freue ich mich auf diese wichtige arbeit
in der ersten enquete kommission
überhaupt die endlich die auswirkung des
außenpolitischen handels von parlament
und regierung in der gebotenen tiefe
endlich analysierte dankbar bin ich
einen sachverständigen die sich mit
ihrer expertise der sachlichen
wissenschaftlichen aufarbeitung an und
diesen prozess aktiv mit gestein
mitgestalten wollen und auch werden die
enquete kommission ist das team das
wissen schafft es das team wissenschaft
das ist ein ganz wichtiger baustein
die
kommission
wird anregungen vorschläge aus den
verschiedenen meinungsspektrum
einarbeiten berücksichtigen ob die
objektive betrachtung gewährleisten und
somit arbeiten keine polemik
die gucken nach links und rechts keine
häme die sie gern von manchen fraktionen
zur schau gestellt werden sondern ein
schloss ein entschlossener aufarbeiten
und lernprozess der einsatz von
politisch neutralen sachverständigen
erlaubt uns zudem unabhängig von den
informationen arbeiten zu können die uns
die regierung bereitstellen könnte wir
sind unabhängig die enquete-kommission
als parlamentarisches institut
unterstreicht die bedeutung des
bundestags wenn es um so grundlegende
fragestellungen wie die ausrichtung und
gestaltung von künftigen
auslandseinsätzen geht und das ist auch
gut so denn es geht darum ich sagte es
bereits die zukunft zu lesen das müssen
wir können denn unsere parlaments armee
gemeinsam mit dem zivilen helferinnen
und helfern künftig in krisengebieten
noch besser effektiver dort hilfe
leisten sollen genauso wichtig ist es
zudem die öffentlichkeit für unsere
arbeit zu sensibilisieren und mit
unserem finanzbericht inhaltlich
korrekte informationen bereitzustellen
mit diesem bericht wird die pulsierende
die information zum thema des
afghanistan-einsatzes endlich ausgeräumt
werden und auch wenn manche politischen
akteure hier sie bei unseren den bürgern
hervorrufen wollen absichtlich
verfälschte fakten und eine daraus
entstehende verunsicherung bei den
bürgerinnen und bürger das hat in
unserer demokratie nichts aber auch gar
nichts zu suchen
und deshalb mussten wir
die zur verfügung stehenden mittel und
gewährt damit kritische objektive und
vor allem mit transparente
auseinandersetzung mit unserem handeln
ich bin froh dass unsere demokratie
diese öffentlichkeit und kontrolle mit
parlamentarischen mit dem herstellt und
gewährleiste die verantwortung für der
zukunft die verantwortung gegenüber
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten die
verantwortung gegenüber den menschen in
krisengebieten die verantwortung
gegenüber den menschen die wir leider
zurücklassen mussten gebietet es dass
uns dieser sache mit aller
ernsthaftigkeit an den vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
ich schließe die aussprache willkommen
zur abstimmung über den antrag der
fraktionen der spd cdu/csu bündnis 90
die grünen und der fdp auf drucksache
2570 zur einsetzung der
enquete-kommission lehren aus
afghanistan für das künftige vernetzte
engagement deutschlands wer stimmt für
diesen antrag das sind die fraktionen
der spd bündnis 90 die grünen fdp und
cdu csu fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das
ist die afg fraktion die fraktion die
linke enthaltungen sich nicht damit ist
der antrag angenommen
also das heißt es wird hier diese
enquete kommission geben die soll auf
sich unverzüglich
konstituieren und spätestens nach der
parlamentarischen sommerpause 20 24 ihre
ergebnisse und handlungsempfehlungen
vorlegen
auch da werden wir natürlich bei phoenix
darüber berichten